what if I told you the reality you know
is one of many last night when we talked
on the red carpet you told me you were
about to go in you see the movie for the
first time what was most surprising
about it all of it you know I mean just
the the it was lovely to see the
audience's reactions as well two things
and on the day you think but putting a
lot into this film but it holds and I
was through I was really really excited
Rachel McAdams also told me that while
you were shooting there were sometimes
some mishaps with the facial hair
they're like what is she talking about
that's what my own fear that's crazy to
Atlanta cause it's not either very fine
makeup artist but I do tend to have
quite a mobile face so yeah it was
incredibly hot innocence as you can
imagine with all that costume so you
didn't just get moments where that would
happen during the scene I have a very
strict rule against dating [ __ ] oh
really
I call it the strange pose oh well good
I'm glad something's named after which
do you think is more secretive Kamaraj
or the MCU oh I think they both hold the
parity there I think what the MCU is
doing so brilliantly it's just slowly
slowly
baby steps huge giant film steps kind of
introducing us to new characters
broadening the landscape and they keep
their cars close enough to their chests
but they also know that fans need to
know something about what's coming next
I find it sort of extraordinary
sometimes to know quite how far in
advance they plan things but Mike Kevin
is he's the real sorcerer supreme so
again another bit of parity with the
avatars yeah he actually came out and
dr. strange we are going to see him in
marvel studios yes Avengers infinity yes
my parents nice about it that's what I
gotta say
but yeah the possibilities are endless
as this film sort of says every night
again and that's very true yeah